all right welcome back to las vegas now
our very own cooking confidence coach
the nanny bubby is back in studio thanks
to chapman automotive the sponsors of
this segment today we are learning how
to make copycat fresh pumpkin scones
yeah your favorite coffee drive through
right yes pumpkin stones are always on
the menu this time of year ready so
there's lots of recipes out there that
copy that amazing
scones so that's what we're going to
make ready yes so first thing that we
have in here i'm just going to run
through it really quick is flour
baking powder baking soda salt cinnamon
ginger cloves light brown sugar and
granulated sugar and this what is that
hazelnut you're close it's nutmeg
have you ever seen fresh nutmeg no no so
that's it look at that can you get a
nice tight shot of that that nutmeg so
i'm going to let you grind it so let me
show you how
so you're going to go home with all
these great you know ideas so just on
there and just put that right into your
dough okay okay got it all right and
while you're doing that i'm going to
talk about honey and i'm going to give
you another nanny bubby tidbit which is
we are going to put that's it you're
good
very cold butter in and the reason you
want it cold is because it's got a lot
of air in it and what happens is as you
mix it it stays in the dough then when
you bake it it's really light and flaky
okay so we'll do that
we'll let that
that's a little bit good
and then here's the big tidbit that i
want to tell you we'll pop this off um
in the wet ingredients it calls for a
tablespoon of honey okay but if you've
ever used honey what happens it sticks
to anything you're measuring whether
it's a cup whether it's a tablespoon so
what you do is you're going to take
coconut oil olive oil avocado oil you
spray it ready okay i'll spray it there
we go now take the you hold that i'll
take the honey
we'll put the honey in
and for people who aren't you know
bakers or really good in the kitchen
this seems fairly simple it is but i
have to tell you my darling you and
you're right in there right
you and your cookie look at that how it
just slides right out right and now you
know you really got a full tablespoon
with and so what happens is your own
confidence just since we've been here
just learning all these little tidbits
look at how good you've been doing i
know i know you were scared to measure
salt when i met you
okay so we're going to just take this
i'm also actually in class
yes yes you're reporting but you're also
in class which i love because you're one
of the best students i've ever had oh go
on i love it you're coming along nicely
and i'm not just saying that okay and so
this is just going to come together
yes but i love kendall too he's a good
student and he likes to coach so you'll
see this is just going to come together
really quick into a ball
wow
they're very fast there it goes
that is a food processor okay so when it
comes out it's a soft dough and what
you're going to do is you're going to
roll out that dough as i make a mess
here in the kitchen but if you're not
making a mess you're not really having
fun so this what comes out like this you
can either use a rolling pin to roll it
okay or you can use your hands and
honestly i do different ways just
depending on how immersed i want to get
into my food and the way that you cut it
is this because you know scones are
triangles right so
one right down like this
and down like this okay now you've got
fours and now you're going to take those
fours and cut them in triangles there
you go
they're just like this you can go all
the way across if you dare right i'm
daring and then
that and then you'll just take each
triangle out place it onto the baking
sheet and away you've got gosh that
looks good just by itself yes it does
and so we're going to move that over
here here we've got the scones all baked
ready to go so just real quickly a
tablespoon of half and half to a cup
okay of powdered sugar this is the icing
so there you go now watch how just a
tablespoon
mixes this oh wow so it starts to become
icing but just in the in the um
reverence of time just pour just a
little bit more in for me
okay that's 45 seconds yep okay so we're
going to ice this and just look at that
oh my gosh i wish you could see the
texture changing yes very very quickly
okay oh you can there we go so we're
going to just ice it like this of course
you'd use a spatula but we don't have
the time and then what i love is just
kind of the right avant-garde well and
then if you look at those coffee house
scones they have 30 seconds yep they
have a second color right over the top
which is this there we go back and forth
there you go a little messy but
beautiful you want to taste it oh my
gosh and you love your your there you go
thank you do you love your your nutmeg
your fresh nutmeg you have to tell mom
and dad about that when you get home for
thanksgiving
it tastes like the holidays
yum that is delicious it isn't it there
we go
time's up
all right wow that's so good thank you
anybody check out nanny baby's kitchen
and garden on social media and online at
nannybubby.com we also
want to thank chapman automotive for
sponsoring the segment kendall i will
send it over to you and no you can't
have one they're all